[Music]
what's in a name
a rose by any other name would smell
just as sweet shakespeare famously said
via juliet
it's difficult to disagree with
shakespeare but i have to respectfully
disagree with him on this matter
the name of a rose or of any other thing
or being for that matter has a direct
implication on its smell
and so much more
my journey for what i nowadays call
global nominal equity nominal not in the
sense of interest rates but nominal as
it relates to names
started at a very cold autumn afternoon
in new england
this was my first year in the united
states my freshman year in college
and here i was waiting for a call back
audition at a small theater in town
first five minutes passed
chris went in i sat and watched others
at the 10-minute mark it was chuck who
went in
at the 15 minute mark it was clayton
i stood up and went to the audition
manager and asked um is there a delay in
the schedule and she said what's your
name i said it's chingus spell that
c-e-n-g-i-z she said uh i don't see a
name like that here you must have been
waitlisted and i'm sorry nobody dropped
out so better luck next time dylan dylan
you're up next
confused and dejected my 18 year old
self went back to the seat and watched a
certain dylan pass by excitedly for his
callback audition
i just wondered why did they not tell me
that i was wait listed why would they
waste my and their time
i just sat there thinking and hoping
that something would happen
that cameron would turn into changus
that christian would turn into changus
nothing turned into chingus
well
it would take me
three years and two months to figure out
exactly what happened that day
my enterprising future self would do
some sleuthing would go in and find out
the audition list from that day
and find that at 2 45 pm
october 29 2014
my name was indeed penned as ching
c-h-i-n-g
come on
it's not even similar
it could not have been
i kept thinking what other things were
lost to me unknowingly simply because
somebody could not remember pronounce or
spell my name
what other things were lost
so it is since then i became emboldened
daily in both quiet and loud ways for
advocates for now what i call global
nominal equity
meaning we should treat each name with
the respect that it deserves and we make
the appropriate accommodations that we
pronounce and spell everyone's name
always everywhere
well if you haven't heard of global
nominal equity before you're not alone
because i just took the creative license
to make it up a couple months ago
and now it's our turn i'm sharing it
with you so that we can co-own it
co-coin it and co-create it together
well
my life has been structured by my name
for a very long time like actually all
the rest of you in the audience
on a good day somebody who meets me for
the first time will say how do i
pronounce your name i will say chingus
with a smile they will say ching is with
a smile and they will continue to
pronounce it without hesitation with a
smile in their eyes with positive
feelings all around
on a bad day however
somebody who meets me for the first time
will say how do i pronounce your name
i will say chingus
and they will say
ah this sounds very difficult i think i
will butcher it so i'm scared i'm just
not gonna say it and then i'll say oh
it's not that difficult come on well
it's two syllables actually it's chin
and giz there's plenty of wobbles and
i'll even sprinkle in a historical
connection by saying it comes from
genghis khan so that it gets anchored in
your mind well their answer is the bad
they remember their answer continues as
saying uh first of all who is that i
don't know and second of all uh it's
really difficult i'll just pass this one
out
to just proceed to interact with me
without mentioning my name ever again
and potentially forgetting many things
that we talked about except one small
fact that my name was unpronounceable
well this doesn't only happen to me in
the broader anglo-saxon universe it also
happens to melee evgeny agnieszka deidra
and adabawale
but we are all perpetrators of this the
number of times i said margot instead of
margot
or genie instead of jean before i was
corrected that he's not a character from
aladdin
was just one too many
and that is why
i believe
that we should make sure that we do not
provide blatant commentary on the most
personal and intimate yet public thing
that we all have are first names
that is exactly why today i chose to
talk to you about the notion of having
an unpronounceable names
and what should we do to ensure that we
treat each name respectfully and make
the appropriate accommodations
one's name
the sound of which the spelling of which
the shape of every letter of which to
dramatize a little bit has a direct
impact on our existence
our self-ideation our public perception
our chances of leaving a legacy our past
and our future
many people we know of went to great
lengths to change their names so that
they could make them more pronounceable
isur danielovic became kirk douglas
natalie herschlag became natalie portman
tint woods became tiger woods
and robert allen zimmerman became bob
dylan and he in fact famously said some
people are just born with the wrong
names
i disagree with them too after
disagreeing with shakespeare
well
actually
research has shown many things about
this front research shows five things
one that people with unpronounceable
names have more difficulty forming
intimate connections
they have more difficulty too they have
more difficulty last leaving a lasting
impression during a job interview
three they have difficulty
having their name being remembered
four they've performed worse at school
and five they have a smaller chances of
being an elected public official
yes even that
unpronounceable names are more likely to
be misremembered and mispronounced even
after correction
and with each
mispronunciation slightly altering our
self-perceived identity
our already complicated existence
our foreignness and our difference
and that is why
it is up to our hands to ensure
that we do not introduce further micro
inequalities into our already deeply
unequal world
and take up the matter into our hands
and find a way in which we treat
everyone with a challenging or an easy
name with the same willingness to
remember
excitement and curiosity
well you might ask how do we do that
it actually starts
very simple with that very very simple
shift it's a mental shift
it starts with realizing one thing
and that is
that no name is actually unpronounceable
it's a little bit duh but it is the
there are no names that are
unpronounceable
if somebody chose to name their child
something this means they were able to
pronounce it
that also means you too after not too
many attempts will be able to pronounce
it
i promise if you cannot pronounce it
right they will correct it
the key is to lean into it not to shy
away from it
there's a lot of shame in not trying but
there's no shame in trying
so the next time when you come across a
name that you immediately deem to be
relatively complicated and
unpronounceable
take a second
think about it in your mind rehearse it
and then say it out loud and then ask
the person did i say it right if you
didn't they will correct it and after
not too many attempts you will
ultimately get it right
well it's sometimes a little bit more
difficult so what you'll have to do my
recommendation is that lean into it a
bit more and then try to use the name
actually refer to the person with the
name without omitting it so every time
you're actually trying to get that
person's attention say the name again
and again and again so that it gets
anchored in your mind and for bonus
points you can even ask what it means
and where it comes from
well it is time
that we make every name pronounceable
not by changing our names but by
changing our attitudes towards them
we need to ensure that we live in a
world in which everybody feels equally
seen and equally respected
it is time that we the ones with
unpronounceable names
have to stop carrying the burden of
others inability to pronounce our names
so to build that equitable world let's
all commit ourselves to making every
word that seemingly unpronounceable
pronounceable and with that every person
that is seemingly foreign intricately
familiar
and to do so let's commit ourselves to
now our co-owned and co-coined term
global nominal equity
thank you
[Music]
you